Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. Or should that be hashtag The Rest Is History? Social media has colonised the world in a way the Romans could only have dreamed of. Does it matter? Does it really shape the world? And is it a new phenomenon? Well, I'm with Tom Holland, who's taking a break from his busy schedule of tweeting his latest thoughts about the desecration of Stonehenge.
感谢收听《历史的 rest is history》。如需每周独家节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的 rest is history》。或者应该叫“#历史的 rest is history”？社交媒体以罗马人做梦也想不到的方式统治了世界。这重要吗？它真的塑造了世界吗？这是一种新现象吗？嗯，我和汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）在一起，他刚刚从忙碌的日程中抽身出来——他最近正忙着在推特上发表对亵渎巨石阵的最新看法。
Social media activism at its best, eh, Tom? Well, I like to think that it is doing some good. The campaign against the Stonehenge tunnel is something that I've been involved with for six years now. And I don't think that I could possibly have done it without social media. It's definitely served to amplify the campaign and to raise the anxieties that we have about the road development. I just don't think it would have happened at all without that. Before you get going, let's get back to the podcast. Can we not just make this entire podcast about the Stonehenge Tunnel? That'll be our 100th podcast. That's something for the listeners to look forward to.
社交媒体行动主义的巅峰，对吧，汤姆？嗯，我认为这确实在发挥一些好作用。反对巨石阵隧道的运动是我参与了六年的一项活动。而且我认为如果没有社交媒体，我根本不可能做到这一点。它绝对起到了扩大活动影响力、提高人们对道路开发担忧的作用。我只是觉得如果没有社交媒体，这一切根本就不会发生。在你继续之前，让我们回到播客正题上来。难道我们不能把整个播客都做成关于巨石阵隧道的吗？那将是我们的第一百期播客。这值得听众们期待。
Could I just say, could I just say, anyone who'd like to help crowdfund our appeal against the government's travesty of a decision, check out at Save Stonehenge on Twitter. Oh, dear, oh, dear. Thank you very much. This has just been a gift to Tom. Right, well, let's start the chat with a tweet.
我能说一下吗，我能说一下吗，任何想要帮助我们众筹上诉、对抗政府那个荒谬决定的人，请在推特上关注“拯救巨石阵”（Save Stonehenge）。噢，天哪，噢，天哪。非常感谢。这简直是送给汤姆的一份大礼。好吧，让我们从一条推特开始今天的聊天。
I mean, there's no other way to start it. And it came from Ollie Simpson. And he sent us this suggestion on hearing what we were going to be talking about. He said, there's that swift quote about mistaking the echo of a coffeehouse, the voice of the coffeehouse mob, for the voice of a kingdom.
我的意思是，没有其他方式可以开始了。这条推特来自奥利·辛普森（Olli Simpson）。当我们谈论即将讨论的话题时，他给我们发了这条建议。他说，有一句关于斯威夫特的著名引言，大意是把咖啡馆的回声、咖啡馆暴民的声音误认为是一个王国的声音。
The 1710 election and explosion of the Tatler, the examiner, the spectator around then seems a candidate for a kind of precedent to what we're going through now. Do you buy that, Tom? I do. And there's not only the Swift quote, there's also a brilliant quote by Burke, who famously said that because half a dozen grasshoppers under a fern make the field ring with their importunate chink, whilst thousands of great cattle reposed beneath the shadow of the British oak chew the cud in the silent, pray do not imagine that those who make the noise are the only inhabitants of the field. And Dominic, you are a massive kind of Twitter, social media sceptic. Yeah, I'm one of the cattle. I'm one of one of the cattle well you're kind of a great bull
1710年的选举以及当时《闲话报》（The Tatler）、《检查官报》（The Examiner）、《旁观者》（The Spectator）的井喷，似乎可以算作我们现在所经历的事情的一种前身。你买账吗，汤姆？我买账。不仅有斯威夫特的引言，埃德蒙·伯克（Burke）也有一句精彩的引言，他曾名言：因为蕨类植物底下的半打蚱蜢使田野里充满它们急切的呢喃声，而千百头高大的牲畜在英国橡树的阴影下静静地反刍，切莫以为发出噪音的就是田野里唯一的居民。多米尼克，你是个彻头彻尾的推特、社交媒体怀疑论者。对，我是那些牲畜之一。我是那些牲畜之一……好吧，你算是一头伟大的公牛……
repose the shadow of a british oak that's oh tom you're too kind very very much how i like to think of you whereas i'm a grasshopper with you are like a cricket an annoying cricket um you'd like the cricket going on and on so is this something new you You know, you took to Twitter straight away. You've sent 20 billion tweets. You have a thousand million followers. Do you think it's a new thing or do you, you know, I know you think everything started with the Persians. The Persians didn't invent social media and the what the way in which it has a divisive effect i think can be traced back to the reformation okay and specifically to luther who i think is the kind of the great exemplar the kind of the great origin point for everything today that we would associate with social media. So Twitter spats, internet flame wars. He had every gift that you would require to be effective on social media. He could come up with aphorisms. He could slag people off. He could denounce fake news he could spread fake news um so just to interrupt you for
在英国橡树的阴影下反刍，噢，汤姆，你太客气了……这非常非常符合我对自己的看法，而我却像一只蚱蜢……你就像一只蟋蟀，一只烦人的蟋蟀……嗯，你会喜欢蟋蟀没完没了地叫。那么，这是什么新鲜事物吗？你知道的，你马上就开始玩推特了。你发了200亿条推特。你有一亿个粉丝。你觉得这是一件新鲜事吗，还是说——我知道你认为一切都始于波斯人。波斯人可没有发明社交媒体，而且它所具有的这种分裂效应，我认为可以追溯到宗教改革时期，好吧，具体来说可以追溯到路德，我认为他是我们今天联想到的与社交媒体相关的一切事物的伟大典范和伟大发源地。所以，推特骂战、网络口水战。他具备在社交媒体上发挥影响力所需的每一项天赋。他能想出格言警句，他会恶语中伤他人，他会谴责假新闻，他会传播假新闻……所以，打断你一下，
a second so luther comes to prominence because he nails his sort of according to myth he nails his 95 theses to the door of the church in wittenberg slagging off the catholic church and calling for you know a reformed church and all the rest of it. And is it, all his stuff is about that, right? It's just a sort of continual campaign, a bit like a Stonehenge campaign, actually. He's just like a sort of 16th century Tom Holland, is he? Well, if you think about the 95 written theses, perhaps as the equivalent of a Twitter thread, you start to move into it. And then you think about the way in which, as the Reformation develops, prints, for instance, illustrations play a key role in propagating the reformer's message. And you think of that as being the
等一下，所以路德之所以声名鹊起，是因为他——根据传说——把他的95条论纲钉在了维滕贝格的教堂大门上，痛骂天主教教会并呼吁建立一个改革后的教会，诸如此类。这一切，他的所有内容都是关于这个的，对吧？这只是一种持续不断的运动，实际上有点像巨石阵运动。他就像是一个16世纪的汤姆·霍兰德，是吗？好吧，如果你把这95条写出来的论纲看作是推特长文（thread）的等价物，你便开始切入正题了。然后你想想随着宗教改革的发展，印刷品——例如插图——在传播改革者信息方面起到了关键作用。你可以把这看作是
equivalent of Instagram. And I think that these aren't entirely tendentious parallels, because in a way, what enables the Reformation is precisely the fact that there is kind of a new medium in the form of printing. And Luther's genius is that he is precisely the fact that there is kind of a new medium in the form of printing. And Luther's genius is that he is able to recognise that and to capitalise on it. But it's not just that Luther kind of comes across a new technology and makes use of it. It's also the fact that it amplifies his core conviction conviction which is that his individual conscience should be the determinant of what he believes rather than the vast edifice of the roman church and so the the the roman church in contrast to the the reformers is kind of ponderous and is slow to wake up to to what is
Instagram的等价物。我认为这些并非完全带有倾向性的类比，因为在某种程度上，促成宗教改革的恰恰是印刷术这种新媒介的存在。路德的天才之处就在于，促成宗教改革的恰恰是印刷术这种新媒介的存在。而路德的天才之处在于，他能够认识到这一点并加以利用。但这不仅仅是路德偶然发现了新技术并加以利用的问题。这也是因为这放大了他的核心信念，即他个人的良知应当决定他所信仰的事物，而不是庞大的罗马教会体系。因此，与改革派相比，罗马教会显得笨拙，对正在发生的事情反应迟钝。
happening and so the reformers in kind of social media terms, you want to put it like that, completely run rings around the Roman church. It takes them a time to start putting out their own memes, their own equivalent of tweets. And the measure of the impact I think that Luther has, and it's a kind of completely staggering statistic, is that over the course of the 1520s which is when luther's really getting going over a fifth of the entire output of pamphlets put out by german presses is is coming from luther wow that's impressive he's completely dominating dominating the airwaves tendentious parallels are something you'll never get in this podcast um but tom i wonder what i wonder what strikes me, right, is that, you know, when you look back at Luther's effusions, they are incredibly aggressive.
因此，用社交媒体的话语体系来说，如果你想这么说的话，改革派把罗马教会耍得团团转。罗马教会花了好一阵子才开始发布他们自己的表情包（memes）、他们自己的推特等价物。我认为路德所产生的影响的衡量标准——这是一个极其惊人的统计数据——是在1520年代，也就是路德真正开始发力的时候，德国印刷厂出版的小册子总量中，有五分之一以上都出自路德之手。哇，真让人印象深刻。他完全主宰了舆论场。带有倾向性的类比是你在这个播客中永远不会听到的，但是汤姆，我想知道，我想知道打动我的是什么，对吧？那就是，当你回顾路德的慷慨陈词时，它们是如此令人难以置信的具有攻击性。
I mean, he's calling people, you know, a fool, an idiot. He uses lots of scatological stuff. Yeah, much worse. Very, very aggressive. I mean, actually far more aggressive than a lot of the remarks that sort of supposedly so scandalous that trolls make on Twitter. And I wonder whether the, what you think about the tendency to abuse, which is, you know, is that something ingrained in the technology or is it in human nature or what?
我的意思是，他骂别人是傻瓜、白痴。他用了大量排泄物相关的词汇。是的，还有更糟糕的。非常非常具有攻击性。我的意思是，实际上比推特上喷子们说的那些所谓的极其丑闻的言论更具攻击性。我想知道，你对这种辱骂的倾向有什么看法？你知道，这究竟是技术中根深蒂固的东西，还是人性使然，或者是什么？
You know, was it in the times? Do you have particular moments when people just like to attack each other? I mean, it's's remarkable isn't it that you know twitter was created and facebook and all these things to bring people together which is this sort of constant human ambition and then straight away people just use them to tell each other people how horrible and stupid they were and in a sense people have always used technology that way haven't they i think that if you look and this is why i think the parallel is is so great and why i think it would be wonderful to kind of do an entire history of the Reformation with tweets. Because what
你知道，是时代使然吗？是否存在某些特定时期，人们就是喜欢互相攻击？我的意思是，这不是很引人注目吗？你知道的，创建推特、脸书和所有这些东西的初衷是为了把人们聚集在一起——这是人类不断追求的目标，然后人们马上就用它们来告诉彼此对方是多么可怕和愚蠢。从某种意义上说，人们一直都是这样使用技术的，不是吗？我认为，如果你看看——这也是为什么我认为这个类比如此贴切，以及为什么我认为用推特来讲述整部宗教改革史会非常棒。因为
happens is that Luther obviously dominates the early stages of the Reformation, but very rapidly he generates, his abuse generates abuse in turn. So it comes from Catholics. Thomas More, you know, wrote this incredibly aggressive stuff back at him, didn't he? Yeah, but it also comes from other reformers who start to cast him as a kind of centrist dad and to complain that he's not going far enough. So, I mean, on the scatological theme,
发生的情况是，路德显然主宰了宗教改革的早期阶段，但很快他就引发了反弹，他的辱骂反过来也招致了辱骂。所以这些攻击来自天主教徒。托马斯·莫尔（Thomas More）不也写了极其具有攻击性的言论回击他吗？是的，但也来自其他改革派，他们开始把他塑造成一个类似“中间派老爸”的形象，并抱怨他走得不够远。所以，我的意思是，关于排泄物这个主题，
Luther is obviously brilliant at that. He's constantly obsessed with his bowels, with excrement, always talking about that. But this generates further kind of shit throwing from Thomas Munster, who is a far more radical figure than Luther, who in the great kind of the war against the peasants, Munster takes the side of the peasants luther doesn't and so munster is um you know he's he's using phrases like donkey farts scrotum like diarrhea makers um since you clearly like drinking shit i hope you brew beer out of shink out of stinking shit he says priests don't talk enough about that do they today no no and and this and so this is and this is the kind of stuff that he is um starting to direct at luther so luther then starts flinging it back and
路德显然是个中高手。他总是痴迷于自己的肠道、粪便，总是谈论这些。但这引发了托马斯·闵采尔（Thomas Munster）更多类似于抛洒粪便的行为。闵采尔是一个比路德激进得多的人物，在大规模的农民战争中，闵采尔站在农民一边，而路德没有。所以闵采尔……你知道的，他使用的是这样的词汇：“驴屁”、“睾丸般的腹泻制造者”……“既然你显然喜欢喝屎，我希望你用发臭的屎来酿啤酒，”他说。现在的牧师对这些谈论得还不够多，对吧？不，不，而这——这就是他开始针对路德的东西。于是路德又开始把这些脏话抛回去。
so it kind of it builds and builds and builds and you can entirely see that in twitter that people get radicalized because people are taking when you get in trench positions people are inevitably driven to attack each other more and more and more, and so it escalates. So it's reasonable, is it, to call the Reformation, I mean, I think it is reasonable to call it a culture war. There's been lots of stuff recently about culture wars, and people sort of get very hot under the collar, and they say, oh, these absurd, confected culture wars. But it seems to me that culture wars are the stuff of politics, and always have been, that actually culture wars are not irrational, or unreasonable, or or anomalous or sort of aberrations. They are the norm. They are the stuff of history. Do you buy that?
所以这种情况不断升级、升级、升级，你完全可以在推特上看到这一点：人们变得激进化了，因为当人们陷入某种立场时，不可避免地会被驱使去更多、更多、更多地攻击彼此，于是矛盾便不断升级。所以，把宗教改革称作一场文化战争，这是合理的吗？我的意思是，我认为称其为文化战争是合理的。最近有很多关于文化战争的讨论，人们对此感到非常恼火，他们说，哦，这些荒谬的、虚构的文化战争。但在我看来，文化战争就是政治的实质，而且一直都是；实际上，文化战争并非不理性、不合理、不正常或是一种畸变。它们是常态。它们就是历史的实质。你赞同吗？
Yes, completely. And I think that the Reformation is absolutely a culture war. And you're right that it's a war because it matters, because for the reformers and indeed for those who are opposing him, this is in a way about more than culture. It's about the destiny of people's souls. It's about the nature of God's plan for humanity. I mean, the stakes couldn't possibly be higher. And so that's why, in a sense, it's driving the abuse. And the same you look at social media today, the most vicious abuse comes from people whose interests and whose values are most under threat. Yes, although there are times, aren't there, where the culture wars seem to die down. So I think about much of, you know, when we were growing up, were culture wars that intense? I don't really think they were. In the sort of 70s, 80s, 90s, they were kind of bubbling along, but they weren't full pelt. I mean, it wasn't something that monopolized people's attention in the same way that the current rows about decolonizing the curriculum or statues or the National Trust or any of these things.
是的，完全赞同。我认为宗教改革绝对是一场文化战争。你说得对，这是一场战争，因为它至关重要。对于改革派以及反对他的人来说，这在某种程度上不仅关乎文化，还关乎人们灵魂的命运，关乎上帝对人类计划的本质。我的意思是，赌注不可能再高了。正因如此，从某种意义上说，这正是促成这种辱骂的原因。同样，如果你看看今天的社交媒体，最恶毒的辱骂来自于那些利益和价值观受到最大威胁的人。是的，尽管有时文化战争似乎也会平息下来。我想到了很多——你知道的，当我们长大时，文化战争有那么激烈吗？我真的不觉得有那么激烈。在70年代、80年代、90年代，它们确实在暗中酝酿，但并非全面爆发。我的意思是，它不像当前关于去殖民化课程、雕塑、国民托管组织（National Trust）或诸如此类的争论那样，垄断了人们的注意力。
There are sort of moments on that. That's what I think is so interesting. There are sort of moments when the latent divides become intensely embittered. And obviously the 16th century was one, and I don't know, the 18th century, or right now, or the 60s maybe. Yeah, I think it's when a technological change happens that enables people to amplify their voices. So the message that, you know, Luther's message was one that
对此总会有一些时刻。这就是我认为最有趣的地方。总会有一些时刻，潜在的分歧会变得异常苦涩。显然16世纪是一个，还有18世纪，或者现在，又或者是60年代。是的，我认为当技术变革发生、使人们能够放大他们的声音时，就会出现这种情况。所以，路德的信息是一个
had been percolating around on the fringes of medieval Christendom for centuries. What Luther was able to do is to make use of the printing press to amplify his voice. And I guess the same, and also because Protestantism puts a premium on reading scripture, therefore it puts a premium on literacy. And the more you have literacy, the more you have people who can read and write. And so that then in turn amplifies the number of people who can kind of join in the culture war. And I guess that in the 18th century, the same thing is happening, that the commercialisation of the press. Right, newspapers and magazines. And coffee houses, as in the famous Swift quote,
在中世纪基督教世界的边缘酝酿了几个世纪的信息。路德能够做到的，是利用印刷机来放大他的声音。我想同样地，也是因为新教高度重视阅读经文，因此高度重视识字率。你越是普及识字率，就会有越多的人能够读写。这反过来又扩大了能够加入文化战争的人数。我想在18世纪，同样的事情也在发生，那就是报刊的商业化。没错，报纸和杂志。还有咖啡馆，正如斯威夫特的著名引言所说，
kind of, again, a bit like, I suppose, a kind of chat room or something, provide a space in which people can meet and discuss and debate. And so I think that culture wars, you know, to have a culture war, you need a battlefield. Well, you do. That's what's so interesting, though, right? That you need an open battlefield, because you need to be exposed, you need. That's what's so interesting, though, right? That you need an open battlefield because you need to be exposed. You need to get to the other side in order to get cross. That's one of the things that strikes me about the development of social media. So what happens now that wouldn't have happened 50 years ago is that people find things. They go out and they find things they really disagree with.
某种程度上——我想类似于聊天室之类的地方——提供了一个人们可以见面、讨论和辩论的空间。所以我认为文化战争，要想发动一场文化战争，你需要一个战场。确实如此。这就是最有趣的地方，对吧？你需要一个公开的战场，因为你需要暴露自己，你需要……这就是最有趣的地方，对吧？你需要一个公开的战场，因为你需要暴露自己。你需要接近对方才能与之争论。这是社交媒体发展带给我的感受之一。所以现在发生的事情在50年前是不会发生的，那就是人们会去寻找一些东西。他们会走出去，寻找那些他们真正不同意的事情。
And then they retweet them to their followers and they say, look at this baboon. What a fool he is writing this article in The Guardian or The Daily Mail or The Telegraph or wherever. And they all pile on in the comments. But people obviously didn't do that in the 1950s. I mean, they didn't get up in the morning and think, I'm extremely left wing. I'm going to go and buy the Daily Express and work myself into a frenzy. People had actually, they were in silos then as much as they are now. And in some ways, it's the fact that the technology allows us to be exposed to the other side that actually inflames people. At least that's my take on it. Yeah. And I think also that it kind of obliges you to have a view on everything. Yeah. So suddenly you'll find that you have very
然后他们把这些转发给他们的粉丝，并说：“看看这个狒狒。他在《卫报》（The Guardian）、《每日邮报》（The Daily Mail）、《每日电讯报》（The Daily Telegraph）或者其他什么地方写了这样的文章，真是个傻瓜。”然后大家蜂拥而至，在评论区大加讨伐。但在20世纪50年代，人们显然不会这样做。我的意思是，他们不会在早晨醒来时想：“我极其左翼，我要去买一份《每日快报》（Daily Express）来让自己陷入狂热。”人们其实——他们当时和现在一样处於信息茧房中。从某些方面来说，正是因为技术允许我们接触到对立面，才真正激怒了人们。至少这是我的看法。是的。而且我认为这也强迫你对每件事都得有个观点。
intemperate views on something that you know absolutely nothing about. Historians are very bad at this, but there's a very nice early edition early edition of question time where they had ajp taylor now ajp taylor was famously opinionated and wrote the inflammatory column for the sunday express and they have him on question time and it gets to about the 10th question and something about housing policy and they ask him ajp taylor what do you think and he says very slowly to be perfectly honest i have no opinion about this at all. And nobody ever says that these days, do they? I mean, most of us do have no opinion about lots of issues, but we feel obliged to confect them, I think partly because social media demands that we confect an opinion,
是的。所以你会突然发现，对于一个你一无所知的事情，你也会产生非常极端的观点。历史学家在这方面很糟糕，但早期有一期非常精彩的《问答》（Question Time）节目，里面有A·J·P·泰勒（A. J. P. Taylor）。现在，A·J·P·泰勒以固执己见著称，并为《星期日快报》（Sunday Express）撰写煽动性专栏。节目请他上了《问答》，大约到了第十个问题，涉及某种住房政策，主持人问他：“A·J·P·泰勒，你怎么看？”他非常缓慢地回答说：“老实说，我对此完全没有任何看法。”如今再也没有人会这么说了，对吧？我的意思是，我们大多数人对许多问题其实都没有看法，但我们觉得自己被迫去伪造一个看法，我想部分原因是因为社交媒体要求我们伪造一个观点，
doesn't it? Although having said that, and here I know that I'm putting words into your mouth, because this is very much the theme of your books on modern British history. It's very much a minority pursuit. Right. And the people who were on Twitter are definitely unrepresentative. I mean, that's what Burke is talking about. That's what Swift is talking about in the context of the 18th century. And your great thesis is that the kind of the cultural revolutions that we associate with the 60s and 70s are minority pursuits. And so
不是吗？话虽如此——在这里我知道我是把自己的观点强加给你，因为这非常符合你关于现代英国历史的书籍的主题——这绝对是一种少数人的追求。没错。而那些玩推特的人绝对是没有代表性的。我的意思是，这就是伯克所谈论的。这就是斯威夫特在18世纪的语境下所谈论的。你的伟大论点是，我们与60年代和70年代联系在一起的文化革命是少数人的追求，所以
I'm guessing that you would think the same about social media in the 21st century, would you? Well, I do, of course. I mean, it's that classic thing, isn't it, that people sort of say, everybody I know voted for Jeremy Corbyn. Everybody on Twitter voted for Jeremy Corbyn, I don't understand, you know, the polls must be wrong or whatever. And that's, I think, I think that's true in the 16th century too. So most people were not reformers. Most people didn't really give an enormous amount of thought to the position of the altar, or the vestments worn by the priest or any of those things. And they're sort of dragged slightly unwillingly behind the enthusiasts and to some extent i think that's how social and cultural change always works but there's a small group of very impassioned people and most people couldn't give a damn they just want a quiet life and and basically the point at which they're going to be
我猜你对21世纪的社交媒体也会持相同的看法吧？嗯，我当然这么认为。我的意思是，这是一个经典的现象，对吧？人们总是说：“我认识的所有人都投了杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）的票。推特上的每个人都投了杰里米·科尔宾的票，我不明白，民意调查一定出错了，诸如此类。”我认为，在16世纪也是如此。所以大多数人并不是改革派。大多数人其实并没有对圣坛的位置、牧师穿的法衣或任何这些事情给予过多的关注。他们有点像是不太情愿地被那些狂热分子拖着走，在某种程度上，我认为社会和文化变革一直都是这样运作的：有一小群非常热情的人，而大多数人根本不在乎，他们只想要平静的生活。基本上，只有当不服从就会被杀头时，
killed if they don't conform they grudgingly go along with the sort of with the enthusiasts but but change is not driven by the sort of great herd as it were by the cattle in the field it's driven by the by people like you by the grasshoppers yes and the and and the change does happen because no one would deny that the reformation had a kind of seismic impact yeah and all these kind of you know luther and munster's kind of yelling at each other is going to have a cumulative effect that will reverberate out across i mean there's a there's a there's a fantastic comment from calvin who um you know is the in a way as as influential on the course of european history as luther but calvin calvin says about luther would that he worked to curb this restless
他们才会很不情愿地顺从那些狂热分子；但是变革并不是由庞大的牛群——也就是田野里的牲畜——所驱动的，而是由像你这样的人、由那些蚱蜢所驱动的。是的，而且变革确实发生了，因为没有人会否认宗教改革产生了某种震撼性的影响。是的，所有这些——你知道的——路德和闵采尔互相大喊大叫，会产生一种累积效应，并在各处回荡。我的意思是，加尔文有一句非常精彩的评论——加尔文……你知道的，他对欧洲历史进程的影响与路德不相上下——但加尔文谈到路德时说：“但愿他能努力遏制这种焦躁不安、心神不定的气质，这种气质动不动就到处沸腾。”这基本上就是说，
uneasy temperament, which is apt to boil over in every direction, which is basic. He's basically saying, I wish he'd stay off Twitter. It's not good. Whereas Calvin's approach is much more, we need to carefully kind of consolidate and seed our ideas. And that, in a way, also proved incredibly effective. Which works, that's the question. Well, they clearly both work.
他基本上是在说：“我希望他别玩推特了。这不好。”而加尔文的方法则要务实得多，我们需要仔细地巩固和播撒我们的思想。从某种程度上说，这也证明了极其有效。哪种方法管用？这就是问题所在。嗯，它们显然都很管用。
But in a sense, Calvin's, I think, Calvin's approach of, which in a way is also, I mean, it's a kind of the prototype for the revolutionary cell meeting up, full of passionate conviction the sort of bolsheviks of their day yeah yes in a way yes yes but i mean what we what you were saying about um supporters of corbyn on twitter i mean because what what they were doing before twitter was standing outside tube stations selling selling magazines and going to meetings with papers and plastic bags and very much not changing the world. Yeah. But Twitter definitely enabled, you know, that kind of absolutely amplified it.
但在某种程度上，加尔文的方法——我认为加尔文的方法，在某种程度上也是一种革命小组会议的雏形，充满了充满激情的信念，可以说是他们那个时代的布尔什维克……是的，在某种程度上是的，是的。但我的意思是，你刚才谈到推特上科尔宾的支持者时……我的意思是，他们在推特之前做的事情是站在地铁站外面卖杂志，带着装有报纸和塑料袋的会议资料去开会，这绝对没有改变世界。是的。但推特绝对使那种行为得以实现，绝对放大了它。
And I guess that in a sense, you know, what's happening with Calvin, who is, you know, he founds his godly republic in Geneva. It establishes a prototype for how a kind of reformed society can exist. And then having done that, then it gets amplified by figures from across Europe who come to it, who go back to their various homelands and write it up so so in the the 16th century the place where calvin is most published most printed most read is not geneva it's london and we can see the impact of that reverberating through into the 17th century um i mean you know calvinism and reaction to calvin's teachings plays a crucial role in the convulsions that send the whole of Britain and Ireland into civil war in the 17th century. But of course,
我想从某种程度上说，加尔文身上发生的事情——你知道的，他在日内瓦建立了他神圣的共和国。它为一个改革后的社会如何存在建立了一个原型。在做到这一点之后，它被来自全欧洲的各路人物放大，他们来到这里，回到各自的故乡并将其实际写出来。所以，在16世纪，加尔文的作品出版最多、印刷最多、阅读最多的地方不是日内瓦，而是伦敦。我们可以看到这种影响在17世纪回荡。我的意思是，加尔文主义以及对加尔文教义的反弹，在将整个英国和爱尔兰卷入17世纪内战的动荡中发挥了至关重要的作用。当然，
it also then gets exported to America. And so, you know, this is seismic stuff. But the funny thing, though, Tom, is that we tell history, we can easily tell history through a series of these culture wars and say, you know, they have long-term repercussions they end up winning you know you can talk I mentioned the Bolsheviks earlier in 1890 in 1900 in 1910 they look like a bunch of cranks who were just sort of talking to each other in sort of dingy rooms above pubs and nobody cares and then they end up winning so we can tell history that way but I suppose there's a more interesting way to tell history which is to write about all those groups in dingy pub history that way. But I suppose there's a more interesting way to tell history, which is to write about all those groups in dingy pubs that don't succeed. I mean, there
它后来也被出口到了美国。所以，你知道，这是震撼性的东西。但有趣的是，汤姆，我们讲述历史时，可以轻而易举地通过一系列这样的文化战争来讲述历史，并说：“你知道的，它们有长期的反响，它们最终取得了胜利。”你可以谈论——我刚才提到了布尔什维克，在1890年、1900年、1910年，他们看起来像是一群怪人，只在酒吧楼上的阴暗房间里互相交谈，根本没人关心。然后他们最终取得了胜利。所以我们可以用那种方式讲述历史。但我想有一种更有趣的方式来讲述历史，那就是写下所有那些在阴暗酒吧里最终没有成功的群体。我的意思是，
are lots of them, right? Not everybody is a Bolshevik or an evangelical reformer who's going to win. And the interesting thing is you don't know. When you embark upon your crusade and you're sort of writing pamphlets or you're tweeting or you're standing outside the tube station with a paper, you may be doomed to utter obscurity and irrelevance so history is not always on your side if you're in the sort of vanguard of change as you see it but it is also the case isn't it and you again will know this better than anyone that it's the people who make the most noise who tend to feature in the history books yeah because historians you know need raw material to put in the book yeah and uh it's very true british cattle you know cattle great cattle beneath the british
有很多这样的群体，对吧？并不是每个人都是布尔什维克或能够取得胜利的福音派改革者。有趣的是，你并不知道。当你开始你的十字军东征、写小册子、发推特或者站在地铁站外面拿着报纸时，你可能注定要陷入完全的默默无闻和无足轻重。因此，如果你处于你所看到的变革先锋地位，历史并不总是站在你这一边。但同样也是事实，对吧？而且你比任何人都更清楚这一点：正是那些制造最多噪音的人往往会在历史书中占有一席之地。是的，因为历史学家……需要原材料放进书中。是的，而且……这非常真实，英国的牛……牛，英国橡树底下的牛，
oak you know they're chewing the card they're not they're not making the noise that the intemperate grasshoppers are so the grasshoppers tend to go in the history books yes and so absolutely it is very difficult to write about people who themselves are not writing. Yes, that's right. I mean, when I was writing about the 60s, I remember talking to my editor. And he sort of said, well, your thesis is, he said, you know, you're having your cake and eating it. Because your thesis is that basically people just went on caravan holidays and played bingo and visited the local Bernie Inn. But to sustain the book, you can't just have that. So you've got the Beatles in it and you've got people having orgies and going to happenings and talking to Harold Wilson and stuff, which is counter to your thesis.
你知道的，它们在反刍，它们没有制造像那些性情急躁的蚱蜢那样的噪音。所以蚱蜢往往会进入历史书中。是的，所以绝对地，要书写那些自己并不写作的人是非常困难的。是的，没错。我的意思是，当我撰写关于60年代的著作时，我记得和我的编辑交谈过。他有点像是说：“嗯，你的论点是……”他说：“你知道的，你这是在自相矛盾。因为你的论点是，基本上人们只是去开大篷车度假、玩宾果游戏、光顾当地的伯尼餐馆（Bernie Inn）。但为了撑起整本书，你不能只有这些。所以你的书里写了披头士乐队（The Beatles），写了人们举办群交派对、去参加各种活动、和哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）交谈等等，这与你的论点背道而驰。”
But you need to have that, otherwise you have no book because you can't have people going for 500 pages on caravan holidays. But Dominic, I mean, looking now at 2020, wouldn't you say that the people, you know, the grasshoppers in the 60s are the people who today have indeed changed the world in a way that people who are going on caravanning holidays in the 60s haven't? Such as? You mean feminism, gay rights, all that sort of stuff? Yeah. And generally that in the culture wars, it's the kind of the people who were the outliers in the 60s who now dominate the battlefield. I find that so depressing, Tom, this conversation.
但你需要这些，否则你就写不出书，因为你不可能让人家读500页关于大篷车度假的内容。但是，多米尼克，我的意思是，现在看看2020年，难道你不认为——你知道的，60年代的那些蚱蜢正是今天真正改变了世界的一群人，而60年代去开大篷车度假的人却没有做到这一点吗？比如什么？你是说女权主义、同性恋权利之类的东西吗？是的。而且总的来说，在文化战争中，正是那些在60年代作为边缘群体的人现在主宰了战场。我觉得这场谈话太令人沮丧了，汤姆。
I think there's some truth in that, but I think it only works if they chime with some sort of subterranean instinct of the cattle, as it were. So in other words, no matter how much you shout about a very unpopular idea, if it's genuinely very unpopular, your shouting is pointless. An example of that is in the 70s, there were people who made a huge hullabaloo about, you know, reforming the laws on sexual consent because they believed that society had got it all wrong about paedophilia, the paedophile information exchange, for example. Now, obviously, they made a big fuss um their cause went nowhere because most people regarded it as utterly repellent so there you have some grasshoppers if you like who are chirping away but they're never going to win they're never going to succeed you know gay rights on the other hand
我认为这其中有一定道理，但我认为只有当它们与牛群某种潜意识的本能相呼应时才起作用，也就是这样。换句话说，无论你如何大声疾呼一个极不受欢迎的想法，如果它本身真的极不受欢迎，你的大喊大叫就是毫无意义的。这方面的一个例子是，在70年代，有些人对——你知道的——改革关于性同意的法律大惊小怪，因为他们认为社会在恋童癖问题上完全搞错了，比如恋童癖信息交流会（Paedophile Information Exchange）。现在，很明显他们大惊小怪了一番……他们的事业毫无进展，因为大多数人认为这极其令人作呕。所以你看，如果你愿意的话，这里有一些唧唧喳喳的蚱蜢，但他们永远不会赢，他们永远不会成功。另一方面，同性恋权利，
there clearly was a growing public tolerance that wasn't necessarily driven by um the people doing the most campaigning but it was rooted in what you know the latent decency shall we say of of sort of people's live and let live attitudes um so i don't think it's necessarily that the that the the more you shout you'll always win and history belongs to you. No, no, no. But I do think that the transformation in values and ethics and assumptions about, say, sexuality would be an obvious one, but gender as well. It's been as rapid as anything, any period in history anywhere. And I would say that actually that the reformation is really the only parallel that i can think of and i think that that maybe in 100 years time the 60s will be seen as equivalent of the 1520s as a period of of kind of where touch papers are lit that just explode and explode and explode and and transform and um you know, how long does it take
显然存在着一种日益增长的公众宽容，这不一定是由那些进行最多竞选活动的人推动的，而是植根于——你知道的——人们“live and let live”（活着也让别人活）态度中潜藏的正直。所以我不认为必然是“你喊得越响，你就总能赢得胜利，历史就属于你”。不，不，不。但我确实认为，在价值观、伦理以及对诸如性行为等假设方面的转变——这是一个显而易见的例子，性别也是如此——其速度之快，堪称历史任何时期、任何地方之最。我要说的是，实际上宗教改革真的是我能想到的唯一的类比。我认为也许在100年後，60年代会被视为1520年代的等价物，被看作是一个导火索被点燃、不断爆炸并最终改变一切的时期。而且……
before people realise that they had lived through something called the Reformation? I think that maybe 100 years. I think people were starting to talk about the Reformation by the 1590s. But people were aware at the time, weren't they? People would say, we are living, you know, there's tons of quotes
你知道，要花多长时间人们才会意识到他们曾经历过一个被称为“宗教改革”的时期？我想也许需要100年。我认为人们在1590年代就开始谈论宗教改革了。但当时的人们是有所觉察的，不是吗？人们会说，我们正在经历……
that people sort of saying quite early on. We're living through very strange times, things that we were told even a year ago. now tell us the king now says um he's changed his mind and actually you know the saints the relics whatever have all been you know people did have a sense of living through as as perhaps people have today anyway um it is long overdue that we took a short break so that tom could check his DMs. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
有很多引言表明人们很早就这么说了。我们正在经历非常奇怪的时期，甚至在一年前还被告知的事情……现在国王告诉我们……他改变了主意，实际上——你知道的——圣徒、圣物等等都已经全被……人们确实有一种正在经历时代的感觉，就像人们今天可能也有的感觉一样。无论如何……我们早该休息一小会儿，好让汤姆去查查他的私信。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Do please remember to rate, review and most importantly,
我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest is history》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest is history》。请记得打分、评论，最重要的是，
subscribe wherever you get your podcasts. And a reminder to get in touch with us on twitter using at the rest history no there's no is in the twitter handle now oddly enough we've got quite a lot of social media about the subject of social media so let's whiz through some of your observations and questions tom holland um here we go with johnny cahill he says um has cancel culture and the desire to drag skeletons out of closets become more prevalent due to the rise of social media? Or has it always been a big part of the political and social landscape of society? Well, Tom, I think it's I think it's always been there. It won't surprise you to learn that. I think that the specifics of cancel culture, the idea that people have to be silenced because they are a moral
无论你在哪里收听播客，请订阅我们。顺便提醒大家，在推特上通过 @therestofhistory 与我们联系——不，推特账号里没有 of 这个词，说来也奇怪。我们收到了很多关于社交媒体主题的社交媒体互动，所以让我们快速浏览一下你们的一些观察和问题吧，汤姆·霍兰德。这里是约翰尼·卡希尔（Johnny Cahill）的问题，他说：取消文化和把黑历史从衣橱里翻出来的渴望，是否由于社交媒体的兴起而变得更加普遍？还是说它一直是社会政治和社交景观中很大的一部分？好吧，汤姆，我认为——我认为它一直都在那里。这不会让你感到惊讶。我认为取消文化的具体特征——即人们因为构成道德威胁而必须被禁言的想法——绝对在当前的形态中，至少在英国和美国，我认为充满了加尔文主义的基调。这在加尔文的日内瓦非常非常重要：那些在道德上令人反感的人应当被禁言、应当受到惩罚。当时存在着一种名为“宗教法庭”（consistory）的组织，其纯粹目的就是为了这个。我认为这种取消文化就像是一个巨大的宗教法庭。但是，汤姆，这难道不是可以追溯到更早吗？古希腊人会把你流放（ostracize）。古罗马人有一种叫做……的东西。记忆抹杀（Damnatio Memoriae）。是的。是的，但取消文化是指你因为你的道德或意识形态价值观而被明确取消。古希腊的流放制度基本上是为了阻止潜在的独裁者，或者阻止民主内部的裂痕扩大到威胁民主未来本身的程度。所以它的运作方式是，每年在公民大会上都会进行一次投票，决定是否应该进行一次流放。
threat, is one that absolutely, in the current form, certainly in Britain and America, I think is imbued with Calvinist undertones. That was very, very important in Calvin's Geneva, the idea that those who were morally offensive should be silenced, should be punished. And there was a kind of organisation called the consistory that existed purely for that purpose. And I think that kind of cancellation culture operates as one immense consistory. But Tom, doesn't it go back further than that? So the Greeks would ostracise you. The Romans had a thing called damnatio something where they... Damnatio Memoria. Yeah. Yes, but cancel culture is you're specifically being cancelled for your moral or ideological values. It basically existed to stop a potential tyrant or to stop fracture lines within the democracy from widening so far that they would threaten the future of the democracy itself. So the way it worked was that every year there would be a vote in the assembly as to whether there should be an ostracism.
这种威胁，以目前的形态来看，在英国和美国，我认为充满了加尔文主义的潜台词。这在加尔文的日内瓦非常非常重要，那种认为在道德上令人反感的人应该被禁声、应该受到惩罚的想法。当时有一种叫做宗教法庭的组织，其存在的目的纯粹就是为了这个。我认为这种取消文化就像是一个庞大的宗教法庭。但是，汤姆，这难道不是可以追溯到更早吗？古希腊人会流放你。罗马人有一种叫什么damnatio的东西，他们……消除记忆。是的。是的，但取消文化是指你因为你的道德或意识形态价值观而被明确取消。它基本上是为了阻止潜在的独裁者，或者阻止民主制度内部的裂痕进一步扩大，从而威胁到民主制度本身的未来。所以它的运作方式是，每年大会都会投票决定是否应该进行流放。
And if they decided there should, then two months later, everyone would meet in the agora and every citizen would write down the name of someone that they wanted exiled for 10 years on an ostracon, which was a kind of shard of pottery. So hence the word ostracism. And whoever got the most votes would then be sent into exile. So that's actually reality television, isn't it? That's the ancestor of Big Brother. Yeah, yeah. I'm a celebrity, get me out of here. I'm an Athenian politician, kick me out. Okay, let's have the next question. So the next question is from somebody I know. He produced a series I once did about the uses and abuses of history. His name is Robbie McGuinness. And he says, this is clearly one for you, Tom, because it's about both Rome and Twitter. Was anyone doxxed in ancient Rome?
如果他们决定应该，那么两个月后，每个人都会在集市（agora）集会，每个公民都会把他们想要流放10年的某人的名字写在陶片（ostrakon）上，这是一种陶器碎片。因此就有了“流放”（ostracism）这个词。谁得到的票最多，就会被流放。这其实就是真人秀，对吧？这就是《老大哥》（Big Brother）的祖先。对，对。《我是名人，放我出去吧！》（I'm a Celebrity...Get Me Out of Here!）。我是一个雅典政治家，把我踢出去吧。好吧，让我们来看下一个问题。下一个问题来自我认识的一个人。他制作过我曾经做过的一个关于历史的用途与滥用的系列节目。他的名字叫罗比·麦吉尼斯（Robbie McGuinness）。他说，这显然是为你准备的，汤姆，因为这既关乎古罗马又关乎推特。在古代罗马，有人被“开盒”（doxxed）过吗？
I don't actually know what doxxing is. Are modern online things like sock puppets and trolling or even swatting, I don't know what swatting is either, are they new or did similar things happen in olden times? Well, doxxing, because I just looked it up in the interval, is apparently putting out malicious information about people. Right, but about people's addresses or something like that. You give people their details and they can...
我其实不知道什么是“开盒”。现代的网上行为比如马甲（sock puppets）、网络喷子（trolling）甚至是“诈弹恶作剧”（swatting）——我也不知道什么是“swatting”——是新鲜事物，还是古代也发生过类似的事情？嗯，“开盒”——因为我在中场休息时查了一下——显然是发布关于人们的恶意信息。没错，但是是关于人们的地址或类似的信息。你把人们的详细信息发出去，他们就可以……
Well, in that case, probably not, because everyone knew where leading politicians in Rome lived. That was the whole point. You couldn't be a leading politician. That's interesting. Everyone knew where they lived. They had no anonymity at all. Yeah.
嗯，如果是那样的话，大概没有，因为大家都知道罗马的政治领袖住在哪里。这就是重点。你不可能成为一个政治领袖却……这很有趣。大家都知道他们住在哪里。他们根本没有匿名性。是的。
No, no. The whole idea about anonymity in Rome was regarded as deviant and suspicious because the only possible reason that any politician could have for wanting to be private was because he was a deviant and a pervert. So you were supposed to live your life entirely in public. OK. So, yeah. So I don't think that would have worked. Yeah.
不，不。在罗马，匿名的整个概念被认为是离经叛道和可疑的，因为任何政治家想要保持隐私的唯一可能原因，就是他是个异端和变态。所以你应该完全在公众目光下生活。好吧。所以，是的。所以我认为这行不通。是的。
But trolling, yes. I mean mean the whole of roman roman political discourse was effectively trolling um and cicero the greatest orator was also the greatest troller um his ability to blacken the reputations of those who opposed him was so i mean mean, was astonishing. And he would have been magnificent on Twitter. Right. I mean, so if you think of social media, one of the purposes of social media is to kind of raise your profile. Then Cicero was a guy who wondered whether people would still be talking about him in 1,000 years.
但是喷子行为，是的。我的意思是，整个古罗马的政治话语实际上就是网络喷子行为。西塞罗（Cicero），最伟大的演说家，也是最伟大的喷子。他抹黑反对者声誉的能力……我的意思是，简直惊人。他在推特上一定会非常厉害。对吧。我的意思是，如果你想想社交媒体，社交媒体的目的之一就是提升你的知名度。那么西塞罗就是一个想知道人们在1000年后是否还会谈论他的人。
Yeah. But was so effective that we're still talking about him 2,000 years in the future. So he would have been superb, I think. Now, the next question, unbelievably, is also for you. It's from somebody called Pat Roberts. And Pat Roberts says, Ask Tom is very prescriptive, or she's very prescriptive. Ask Tom how Aristides the Just got ostracised, the original trolling of a virtue signaller. And ask how Socrates' views on kids learning to write compare with the disapproval of smartphones. Okay, so Aristides the Just was ostracised. A virtue signaller? Yes, I think so, because the story goes that he was in the marketplace, the ostracism was happening.
是的。但他的成效如此显著，以至于我们在2000年后的今天仍在谈论他。所以他会非常出色，我想。现在，下一个问题，令人难以置信的是，也是给你的。它来自一个叫帕特·罗伯茨（Pat Roberts）的人。帕特·罗伯茨说：“问问汤姆”是非常专断的——或者说她非常专断。“问问汤姆，正义者阿里斯蒂德（Aristides the Just）是如何被流放的，这是对道德优越感展示者（virtue signaller）最初的网络喷子行为。再问问苏格拉底对孩子们学写字的看法与对智能手机的反对有何可比性。”好吧，所以正义者阿里斯蒂德被流放了。一个道德优越感展示者？是的，我想是的，因为故事是这样的：当时他在集市上，流放投票正在进行。
Some out-of-town guy who couldn't write came up to him and said, please would you write down Aristides? I want him ostracised, not recognising who Aristides was. And so Aristides understandably said, why do you want him sent into exile? And the guy said, because I'm fed up with everyone going on about how he's the just. So it's a nice story. But of course, if the story is true,
一个从外地来的、不会写字的家伙走到他面前说：“请你帮我写下‘阿里斯蒂德’好吗？我想把他流放。”却没有认出阿里斯蒂德本人是谁。于是阿里斯蒂德可以理解地问：“你为什么要流放他？”那家伙说：“因为我受够了每个人都在喋喋不休地谈论他有多么正义。”所以这是一个很好的故事。当然，如果这个故事是真的……
you have to wonder who told it. The only conceivable candidate is aristides himself um so so maybe he was virtue signaling about being ostracized for his own virtue signaling is that what you're yes absolutely yeah words yes that's very and socrates view on kids learning to write well so socrates um it's actually of course plato who is ventriloquising for Socrates. And Socrates tells a story about a pharaoh who is approached by the Egyptian god Thoth who has invented writing. And Thoth comes along to the pharaoh and says, look, isn't this a brilliant invention? And the pharaoh says, no, it's terrible.
你不得不怀疑是谁说的。唯一能想到的候选人就是阿里斯蒂德本人，所以也许他是在进行美德宣示，为了自己因美德宣示而被流放而进行美德宣示，是这样吗？是的，绝对是的，是的，词语，是的，这非常符合苏格拉底对孩子们学习写得好的看法。所以苏格拉底，实际上，当然，柏拉图是在借苏格拉底之口抒发观点。苏格拉底讲了一个故事，说有一个法老，埃及神明透特来找他，透特发明了文字。透特找到法老说，看，这不是一个极其 brilhante（辉煌）的发明吗？法老说，不，这太糟糕了。
We don't want to have this new technology. Basically because it will culminate in Twitter. And that would be just as bad. So the fairy lists all kinds of reasons why writing is a terrible idea and why children shouldn't learn it. But of course, again, there's a kind of paradox there because Plato, who is writing this,
我们不希望有这种新技术。基本上是因为它最终会导致推特（Twitter）的出现。那也会同样糟糕。所以法老列举了各种理由，说明为什么文字是个糟糕的主意，为什么孩子们不应该学习它。但是，当然，这里面又有一种悖论，因为正在写下这一切的柏拉图，
is one of the supreme literary artists of all time and the only reason that we know um this story is because plato wrote it down so there's a kind of moebius strip of complexity there it's so interesting isn't it there's stuff about technology so in my books about post-war britain i've written about two things well three things really about which people had exactly the same reaction. One is television, the next one is home computers, and the other one is more specifically video games. And people said exactly the same thing about all of those things.
是有史以来最卓越的文学艺术家之一，我们之所以知道这个故事，唯一的原因就是柏拉图把它写了下来，所以这里有一种莫比乌斯环般的复杂性，非常有趣，不是吗？里面有很多关于技术的内容——在我关于战后英国的书里，我写过两件事，或者说三件事，人们对它们的反应完全一样。一个是电视，下一个是家用电脑，还有一个更具体的是电子游戏。对于所有这些东西，人们的反应完全一样。
Children will get addicted, it saps the morals of the young, they used to grow up and read the books of G.A. Henty, and now they are watching Tizwas or playing Space Invaders. And the stories are the same. The only thing that differs are the names. The columns are exactly the same. But a good example of somebody who campaigned against television was Mary Whitehouse, who you will remember, a big figure in our childhoods campaigning against people watching too much TV and obscenity on TV. And the way that she became popular or she became well known was, of course, through TV. She appeared on the very technology that she was denouncing. So in that sense, you know, the often used comparison between Mary Whitehouse and Plato,
孩子们会沉迷其中，它会腐蚀年轻人的道德，他们过去常常长大后阅读G.A.亨蒂的书，而现在他们在看《Tizwas》或者玩《太空侵略者》。故事都是一样的，只有名字不同。专栏的内容完全一样。但是，反电视运动的一个好例子是玛丽·怀特豪斯（Mary Whitehouse），你可能还记得她，在我们童年时期是一个大人物，反对人们看太多电视以及电视上的淫秽内容。而她变得受欢迎或知名的方式，当然是通过电视。她出现在她所谴责的技术上。所以从这个意义上说，人们经常把玛丽·怀特豪斯和柏拉图进行比较，
ventriloquizing Socrates, is entirely vindicated. That's what this podcast is all about. Where else would you get comparisons between Plato and Mary Whitehouse? Plato, Whitehouse, Parallel Lives. That's a book waiting to be written. This is from someone called Jonners. The Gettysburg Address has to be the tweet of the day, short and snappy, comparatively.
借苏格拉底之口说话，这是完全被证实的。这就是这个播客的全部意义所在。你在哪里能找到把柏拉图和玛丽·怀特豪斯进行比较的地方？柏拉图、怀特豪斯，《名人并行传》。那是一本等待被写出来的书。这是来自一个叫乔纳斯（Jonners）的人。葛底斯堡演说一定可以说是当天的推文，简短而有力，相对而言。
And that's an important point, isn't it? Yeah. It's a very important point. It's got to be short, it's got to be abbreviated and um that's often the case with the most celebrated phrases um yeah and soundbite culture is not new so you know soundbite culture um you always needed i think in the age of literacy you always needed a short snappy phrase that the public could remember i mean the idea that people would sort of go and listen you know people there's all these stories about people going to listen to Gladstone,
这也是一个重点，不是吗？是的。这是一个非常重要的重点。它必须简短，必须缩写，而且最著名的短语往往就是这样，是的，金句文化并不新鲜，所以你知道，金句文化，在识字时代，你总是需要一个简短有力的短语，让公众能够记住，我的意思是，人们会去听，你知道，有所有关于人们去听格莱斯顿（Gladstone）演讲的故事，
for example, hundreds of thousands of people or tens of thousands of people. The truth is, of course, most of those people wouldn't have been able to hear him. They'd have only heard sort of snippets passed back. So getting the snippets right has always mattered. And I think brevity has always been a virtue for sort of politicians and political leaders. You think of Elizabeth I at Tilbury, you know, though I am a woman, I have the sort of stout heart of a man and all that kind of business, all that carry on. That's the line that everybody remembered at the time. And that's the line, well, they remembered.
例如，成百上千人或成万的人。但事实当然是，其中大多数人根本听不见他说话。他们只能听到传过来的零星片段。所以把这些片段弄对一直都很重要。我认为对于政客和政治领袖来说，简练一直是一种美德。你想想伊丽莎白一世在蒂尔伯里的演讲，虽然我是一个女人，但我有着男人般坚强的心，诸如此类的事情，所有的折腾。那是每个人当时都记住的那句话。这也是那句话，好吧，他们记住了。
I mean, that's the invented line put in her mouth that people remembered at the time. And that's the line that's endured. And I think it's always been the case that short and snappy is better than long and windy. Beini vidi vici. There you go. Very good. I saw I conquered. Yep.
我的意思是，那是放进她嘴里人们记住的发明出来的话。这也是流传至今的话。我认为简短有力一直比又长又啰嗦要好。Veni, vidi, vici（我来，我见，我征服）。就是这样。非常好。我看见，我征服。是的。
Yep. Which was put on a placard that followed Caesar with his triumph so that everyone could read it. And, you know, it went viral. It's viral to this day. Everyone still still knows it. so that everyone could read it and you know it went viral it's viral to this day everyone still still knows it um okay here's here's another from francis stratford please explore anti-popery as a culture war it defined this nation after all okay so that's that's kind of going back to the reformation idea the idea that became very distinctive in um in britain that uh catholicism in Britain that Catholicism was evil,
是的。这句话被写在标语牌上，跟随着凯撒的凯旋游行，以便每个人都能读到，而且，你知道，它病毒式传播了。直到今天它依然在病毒式传播。每个人仍然都知道它。以便每个人都能读到，而且，你知道，它病毒式传播了。直到今天它依然在病毒式传播，每个人仍然都知道它。好吧，这里还有来自弗朗西斯·斯特拉特福（Francis Stratford）的另一条：请探讨反天主教（anti-popery）作为一场文化战争，毕竟它定义了这个国家。好吧，所以这有点回到宗教改革的想法，一种在英国变得非常独特的想法，即英国的天主教，天主教是邪恶的，
that Protestantism defines the nation. And I guess we've already done an episode on the 17th century, but that was the idea, you know, anti-popery could fake history. Anti-popery is a culture war, is a culture war. And the funny thing is,
新教定义了这个国家。我想我们已经做过一期关于17世纪的节目了，但当时的理念就是这样，反天主教可以伪造历史。反天主教是一场文化战争，是一场文化战争。有趣的是，
if you think about it that way, Britain is founded on a culture war. I mean, Britain the funny thing is if you think about it that way britain is founded on a culture war i mean britain is the protestant chosen nation isn't it that when england scotland came together after 1707 it was their shared protestantism and their opposition to catholic france that bound them together so a culture war is at the essence of britishness sense of Britishness. Yes, and all the stuff that we would recognise now, kind of fake news, stings, memes, everything is there. Yeah, you think about all the stuff about the 30 Years' War
如果你从这个角度来想，英国就是建立在一场文化战争之上的。我的意思是，英国，有趣的是，如果你这样想，英国是新教选民国家，不是吗？当英格兰和苏格兰在1707年后联合在一起时，正是他们共同的新教信仰以及对天主教法国的反对将他们结合在了一起，所以文化战争是英国人身份认同的核心。是的，所有我们现在能认出的东西，比如假新闻、设局陷害、表情包（memes），一切都在那里。是的，想想所有关于三十年战争的事情，
that circulated in the 17th century. That's classic meme stuff, isn't it? The sort of images of... The types of oats and... Yeah, all that sort of stuff all catholics abroad are murdering protestants and here are some here's a nice woodcut of a massacre i mean that's pure kind of um and also and also blaming disasters on catholics so the great five london great five london uh yeah everything's catholics okay um now here's a good point that
这些在17世纪广为流传。这绝对是经典的表情包内容，不是吗？各种图像……燕麦的种类……是的，所有这些东西，所有的海外天主教徒都在屠杀新教徒，这里有一些，这里有一幅大屠杀的精美木刻版画，我的意思是，这纯粹是一种……而且还有，把灾难归咎于天主教徒，所以伦敦大火……伦敦大火……是的，一切都是天主教徒干的。好的，现在这里有一个很好的观点，
we've alluded to a little bit earlier, but it comes from David Knowles. David Knowles says, yesterday's culture often becomes today's orthodoxy. So what divisive thing do you think from today could become commonly held tomorrow? And what are some surprising culture wars from the past about topics that we wouldn't realise were controversial? So let's take the first point. What divisive thing do we think will become the orthodoxy tomorrow? That is a good question. And I'm glad you asked it. And I think that perhaps you should, as the modern historian, should answer that. OK, well, to me, the obvious thing actually is vegetarianism.
我们刚才稍微提到过一点，它来自大卫·诺尔斯（David Knowles）。大卫·诺尔斯说，昨天的文化往往成为今天的正统。那么，你认为今天有什么具争议性的事物可能会成为明天普遍接受的信条？过去有哪些令人惊讶的文化战争，涉及我们现在不会意识到存在争议的话题？让我们先探讨第一个问题。你认为明天什么具争议性的事物会成为正统？这是一个好问题。很高兴你问了这个问题。我想作为现代历史学家，你也许应该回答这个问题。好吧，对我来说，显而易见的事情实际上是素食主义。
I think I always think that will be the thing that people I mean, I I'm not a vegetarian and I can't imagine ever being one. But I think there will be a point in, let's say, the 27th century when people will look back on us and they will say, God, what awful people. They knew the damage it was doing. They knew the cruelty and the ecological damage and all the rest of it. And yet they still went out and they ate their chicken korma or their fillet steak or whatever it might be. And I suspect that will be the thing that people will judge us for. Yeah, I kind of became vegetarian-ish.
我总是认为这将是人们——我的意思是，我不是素食主义者，我也无法想象自己成为素食主义者。但我认为在比如说27世纪的某个时候，人们会回看我们，他们会说，天哪，这是多么可怕的一群人。他们明明知道这造成的破坏。他们明明知道其中的残忍、生态破坏以及其他所有后果，然而他们仍然出去吃他们的鸡肉科尔马咖喱、菲力牛排或随便什么别的。我猜这将是人们评判我们的事情。是的，我某种程度上变成了“类素食主义者”。
Can you be vegetarian-ish? Five years ago. Well, to the degree that I eat fish, so that doesn't really make me a vegetarian. You don't eat steak? I'm a pescatarian. Do you only eat the roast beef of Old England, Tom? No, I don't. I don't.
你可以当类素食主义者吗？五年前。嗯，就我吃鱼而言，所以这并没有真正让我成为素食主义者。你不吃牛排？我是个吃素食加鱼类者（pescatarian）。你只吃老英格兰的烤牛肉吗，托姆？不，我不吃。我不吃。
And, you know, I do feel morally purer than you as a result. Well, I knew that. I mean, that was pretty obvious. Yes, I do look down on you. That's been obvious from the very beginning of this podcast i think yes i well i i'd agree with that um and i think not least because technology again is clearly coming to the rescue so this week we've had um story about um people in singapore basically inventing meat chicken yeah nuggets um yeah so
而且，你知道，结果我确实觉得自己比你更有道德纯洁感。好吧，我早就知道了。我的意思是，那太明显了。是的，我确实看不起你。我想从这个播客一开始这就很明显了。是的，我，我会同意这一点，而且我认为，不仅是因为技术再次明显前来救援，所以这周我们有一个关于新加坡人基本上发明了人造肉，鸡肉，对，鸡块，对，所以
the thought that i might be able to go back to eating chicken you see chicken chicken i couldn't possibly eat a chicken now because they are the closest living relatives to tyrannosaurs and anything more disrespectful than eating a tyrannosaur you wouldn't eat a dino that's madness right i couldn't eat a dinosaur we've got one more yeah and then but then david also asks what is some surprising culture wars from the past about topics that we wouldn't realize were controversial i guess i mean i guess for um looking at my my children and the things that they take for granted that were still controversial when i was young i guess i mean i guess homosexuality would be the i was going to say that's the obvious one isn't it i mean when mean, when we were growing up, you know, it was a very hotly contested issue.
我可能会重新开始吃鸡肉的想法，你看，鸡，鸡，我现在绝对不可能吃鸡肉了，因为它们是暴龙（霸王龙）现存最近的亲戚，还有什么比吃一只暴龙更不尊重的事吗？你不会吃恐龙的，这太疯狂了，对吧？我不能吃恐龙。我们还有一个，是的，然后大卫还问，过去有哪些令人惊讶的文化战争，涉及我们没有意识到会有争议的话题？我想，看看我的孩子们以及他们认为理所当然的事，而这些在我年轻时仍然充满争议，我想，我想同性恋会是——我正要说，那是显而易见的那个，不是吗？我的意思是，当我们长大时，你知道，这是一个争论非常激烈的话题。
When was it decriminalised? So 1967, I think. 1967, so I was born in 1968. So I was born one year after, you know, a year before I was born. It was still illegal. And, of course, the stigma, as it were, the sort of the, it remained reasonably contentious and for, you know, 10, 20 years, didn't it? Yes. Yeah. But I mean, the idea that, that, that, um, a year before I was born, homosexuality was illegal. And now essentially it's illegal to be
它是什么时候非罪化（合法化）的？所以是1967年，我想。1967年，所以我出生于1968年。所以我出生在它（非罪化）一年之后，你知道，在我出生前一年，它仍然是非法的。当然，那种耻辱感，随之而来的，某种程度上，它仍然具有相当的争议性，持续了，你知道，10年，20年，不是吗？是的。是的。但是我的意思是，在我出生前一年，同性恋是非法的，这个想法……而现在，基本上反对同性恋是
opposed to homosexuality. I mean, that is an astonishing process of change. Yeah. I mean, there are people now, there are lots of people now who were brought up to believe, who believed for long periods of their life that it was sinful or sort of some way medically wrong, that you needed medical help or you should be judged. And that has now become, I mean, that's a hate but you see i think that's why that's why the parallel with the reformation is an interesting one because a similar process of change happened in in england yeah um over the course of a century things that had been completely taken for granted by everyone in england became utterly criminalized you know we just talked about anti-popery in england was a famously
违法的。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的变革过程。是的。我的意思是，现在有些人，有很多人从小就被灌输，在他们生命中的很长一段时间里都相信这是有罪的，或者在某种程度上是医学上有问题的，你需要医疗帮助或者你应该受到审判。而现在这已经变成了——我的意思是，那是一种仇恨，但你看，我认为这就是为什么与宗教改革的平行对比很有趣，因为英国也发生过类似的变革过程，是的，在一个世纪的时间里，所有英国人原本认为是理所当然的事情，变得彻底被定为刑事犯罪，你知道，我们刚才谈到反天主教，英国曾经是一个著名的
pro-papal nation um it was it was uh it had a particular the english were famed for their devotion to the virgin mary we were you were talking earlier about telling the story you know you can tell the story from the perspective of the grasshoppers or you can tell it from the perspective of the cattle but there's another group of people you can tell history through which whom we almost never look at, which are those people who have been left behind. So those people who are sitting there bewildered and are sort of saying, well, I haven't changed.
亲天主教的国家，它曾经有……英国人以对圣母玛利亚的崇拜而闻名。你刚才在讲故事，你知道，你可以从蚂蚱的角度来讲故事，或者你可以从牛的角度来讲故事，但还有另一群人，你可以通过他们的视角来讲述历史，而我们几乎从来没有关注过他们，那就是那些被时代抛在后面的人。也就是那些坐在那里感到不知所措，然后说，好吧，我没有变，
But the world has gone mad. Everything I've been told when I was a child, that my parents and grandparents taught me, has been turned on its head. What's happened? And at any moment in history, there are always people who think like that aren't there and again i think that technology has speeded that up because i think that that you know that is a process that you can trace through the middle ages so often
但世界疯了。我小时候被告知的一切，我的父母和祖父母教给我的东西，全都被颠倒过来了。发生了什么？在历史上的任何时刻，总会有这样想法的人，不是吗？再次我认为技术加速了这一进程，因为我认为这是一个你可以贯穿整个中世纪追踪的过程，通常
people who are condemned by um people in the commanding heights of the church in the middle ages as as heretics are simply holding to beliefs and practices that were the orthodoxy maybe a century before. You know, they live in the kind of, you know, in the sticks away from the universities or Rome. And so they have no idea that actually they've now become branded as herit... well, deplorables, I suppose you could say. And the more technology speeds up, so the quicker they become branded as deplorables. Yeah, they're the equivalent of the people who use the wrong word now, the wrong word that they thought was reasonable 20 years ago, and they haven't noticed. And everyone's haranguing
在中世纪被教会统治高层谴责为异端的人，其实只是在坚守或许一个世纪前还是正统信仰的信条和习俗。你知道，他们生活在远离大学或罗马的乡下，所以他们根本不知道自己实际上已经被打上了异端——好吧，可以说是“可悲之人”（deplorables）的烙印。技术发展得越快，他们被打上“可悲之人”烙印的速度就越快。是的，他们就相当于那些现在用了错误词汇的人，用了他们20年前认为合理、却没有注意到现在不行的词汇，而每个人都在声讨
them and saying, why haven't you educated yourself? And all this kind of thing. Yes. And I think also that what that shows is that very rapid change tends to be driven by the educated. Education is a marker of status and wealth. And so almost invariably not to be educated. You know, people say educate yourself. If you're saying that, you are assuming that you yourself are educated. Yeah. So education has always been a marker of status and that's true of of clerks in the middle ages of um reformers based in london and the university towns in
他们，并说，你怎么不提升自我？诸如此类的话。是的。我也认为，这表明非常快速的变化往往是由受过教育的人推动的。教育是地位和财富的标志。因此，几乎无一例外地，不要没受过教育。你知道，人们说“提升自我（educate yourself）”。如果你这么说，你就是在假设你自己是受过教育的。是的。所以教育一直是一个地位的标志，无论是中世纪的文士，还是位于伦敦和大学城的改革派，
in reformation england it's true now again it's people based in london and university towns who are kind of at the forefront of social media and condemning people for using the wrong language having the wrong views yeah all right tom we've gone on for far too long. There is no doubt that social media is one of the great talking points of our time. So if you can't beat them, join them. Send us your thoughts using our Twitter handle at TheRestHistory or to me at DCSanbrook or to Tom at Holland underscore Tom. Thank you for listening. See you next time. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access,
在宗教改革时期的英格兰是如此，现在也是如此，身处伦敦和大学城的人们再次处于社交媒体的前沿，谴责他人使用了错误的语言、抱有错误的观点。好吧，汤姆，我们聊得太久了。毫无疑问，社交媒体是我们这个时代最热门的话题之一。所以，如果你打不过他们，就加入他们。使用我们的推特账号 @TheRestHistory，或者发给我 @DCSanbrook，或者发给汤姆 @Holland_Tom，把你的想法发送给我们。感谢收听，下期再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、
ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。